all right so the Mandalorian season 3 is
now at the halfway point and after
almost an hour-long episode last week
we're back with one that's half the
length like your ex's new boyfriend
you know I've always got your back and
this video we're going to be breaking
down the Mandalorian season 3 episode 4.
packed with Star Wars Easter eggs hidden
details and a lot of hints to where
things will be going in the future we're
gonna be going through it all in this
recap video now last week saw Mando and
Bell Katan exiting the Living Waters of
Mandalore completely cleansed and after
they were sworn By Thai interceptors
Bo's home was destroyed episode 3 kinda
took a segue from there and made us get
up close and personal with the Empire's
number one cloner led into an entrapment
situation with a liar Kane he was
captured and tortured by the Spy which
is when we cut back to Mando and Beau we
then saw her meeting with the omra and
also her group which is when they were
welcomed in and now part of the family
now we are going to be getting into
episode 4 in just a second but first
just a quick word from this video's
sponsor so we can help pay some bills
and don't go anywhere because you are
number one subscriber okay so little
quiz time what is the advert gonna be is
it a VPN some cool headphone phones no
it's rage Shadow Legends you probably
heard the name before but do you know
what you're missing out on the game has
hundreds of Champions to collect a super
in-depth battle system amazing graphics
and intense PVE boss fights great Shadow
Legends is one of the best mobile games
available and it's a must play that you
have to download right now the game is
celebrating its fourth anniversary and
we've teamed up with them to bring you a
cool free starter pack but this ad I
decided to get creative for once and I'm
gonna spell out why you should download
right using the letters raid first up
with r is their rewards due to their
amazing referral program the more
friends that you get to play it the more
you'll get back for your Champions A is
for arena in which you can test your
strength against other players I is for
Eragon the Eternal dragon and if you've
played the game then you'll know this
Doom Tower boss is a big challenge that
will keep you on your toes lastly is D
for the Demon Lord this is a massive
Challenge and a great way to earn
powerful daily resources like shards and
gems once you master it but the fourth
anniversary they're doing lots of big
dedicated offers giving away free gifts
promo codes events and a brand new
Fusion event that will let you get your
hands on an anniversary themed Champion
with it being a big anniversary you can
also take a trip down memory lane with a
recap video to show all your stats in
raid Amazon Prime members will also get
an exclusive drop with some powerful
Sage gear that's available between now
and the 30th of March but there's more
new players scan my QR code or click the
link in the description and you'll be
given a free starter pack and this cool
in-game loot just scan that or click the
link in the description below to
download the game and start playing now
thanks now episode 4 is called the
foundling and it's directed by Carl
Weathers balings are of course a big
thing in Star Wars lore and the term is
primarily used in Mandalorian culture it
means a child that was found by the
mandalorians That Was Then adopted in
their ways and we've seen this in the
case of dinjar and grogu we start off at
the Mandalorian cover with m training
away and this includes a child that got
baptized in the first episode of the
Season my man over here has the most
rigid shot I've ever seen but it's such
a dynamic way to open the episode that
potentially highlights where we could be
going in the season with a big all-out
Mandalorian War now according to the
leaks on the episode that talked about
the costume parts of these mandalorians
armor actually come from repurposed
Stormtrooper outfits I really hope
that's true too and it shows just how
scared that the mandalorians are when
best cars in such a short supply that
they have to resort to that many of the
suits we see are similar to dins at the
start of the first season and it shows
how downtrodden they are and how far
he's come now juxtaposing this violin
concern over the top training we see
grago doing his own with a circle of
stones he moves them with the force
seemingly and this of course is similar
to what Luke did during The Empire
Strikes Back when he trained with Yoda
nice little bit of grogu grabbing a
shellfish uh because he always he's
always after food and most of the stones
end up being revealed to be them so
maybe he didn't move this Stone so mate
you don't have the force you're pathetic
anyway we see a little Apprenticeship
Training Program and the mandalorians
are very much mirror the Jedi in several
ways they take children in from a young
age indoctrinate them into their ways
and even the words foundlings and
Apprentice are used within both groups
Now new kid on the Block doesn't see
grogu as being worth fighting because he
doesn't have a helmet yet my guess is
that at some point we will see him get
one the wrist straps they're given have
three dots in them and Django used
something similar during attack of the
Clones and his solo game Bounty Hunter
when Made Lethal their one-hit kills and
sometimes they contain poisonous fluid
that paralyzes the target before then
killing them it's painful practice
though with a kid getting the first two
shots but then grogu does a flip go and
do a flip and he gets the victory it's
good seeing the guy come out on top but
the victory short-lived when they're
attacked by one of the planet's
inhabitants honestly I don't know why
they still hung around this Lake after
what happened in episode 1 and it's even
dumber when you find out that there's
dragons done this attack several times
before I think it kind of speaks to the
pride that the mandalorians have and how
can often lead to them doing stupid
things that aren't really worth it in
the end last week we talked about
whether Mandalore was even worth saving
and I kind of get that same feeling here
with him hanging out of this cave
they're very much we won't move you move
and this has caused the constant
conflict and in fighting that's happened
with the group in the past now the
history of Mandalore is pretty
convoluted due to all the Civil Wars and
political changes that the planets had
to deal with Mandalore existed on its
own without outside influence until the
tongs arrived and they discovered a
planet Rife with new opportunities
amongst the ranks of the tongs was
mandal or the great and in order to
assert dominance he took down the beast
at the top of the food chain that was
the mythosol and this happened in a time
before people had access to the more
high-tech weapons that the franchise is
famous for the guy took it down
single-handedly and gained a lot of
respect from his tribe which is when
they decided to name the entire planet
after him from this point on the
mythosaurs became the symbol of the
Mandalorian a Mandalore create a helmet
out of the skull of the slain mythosol
it's also said the style of the Creed
would carry on from that point onwards
and the character became one of the most
important people on the planet over the
centuries the Jedi and mandalorians
juked it out until a Mandalorian Jedi
called tarvis LaRosa he created the
darksaber and this became the weapon
that every Mandalorian rallied behind
who actually met one of his descendants
in Paz for Isla whose voice by none
other than John Favreau I've already
went into theories about how he might
unmask it and Show Jon Under The Helmet
but people always kick off so I'll not
do that I said I'll not do it I'll not
even mention it I'll just stick to the
darksaber anyway the wield of that has
been seen as someone who's fit to lead
the mandalorians and the blade can also
only be won in combat this is why nobody
followed Beau because originally she was
given it by Sabine rather than taking in
a battle Beau ended up following one of
its hole as in previously but he was
killed by Darth Maul who then took the
weapon and also the planet after this it
was found by Sabine who handed it to
Beau before she went on to lose it to
moff Gideon anyway that's a brief
history of the planet but it's important
to bear in mind that Civil Wars have
completely destabilized Mandalore adobo
is clearly being painted out as one of
the good guys you have to bear in mind
that she also has her own wants and
desires but believed that she would be
the leader of the planet and she thinks
that it's her birth right to rule a bow
is tracked the dragon on her ship The
Gauntlet and they form a Hunting Party
in order to get the boy back we get a
scene that riffs on the Death Star
trench from planning and in that they
talked about how the Easter Bullseye
womp rats back on Tatooine this was
roughly the size of the exhaust port and
Beau talks about how the mountains are
no higher than the peaks of kiram Kiama
root which used to climb when she was
younger these mountains have actually
been mentioned in the Saga before and
the area was home of the scarada clan
before the clone wars happened burst
mentioned in Republic Commando True
Colors this has become a major place to
escape persecution for those seeking to
flee the Imperials I out of the Clone
Wars it was used as a refuge for clan
Troopers and these were the ones who
decided the Grand Army of the Republic
now the armor also mentions the SRI Corp
group accompanying Paz and SRI corks
were a predatory bird that was native to
Mandalore driven to extinction by the
Mandalorian cataclysm their Signet was
used by the clan visler and then later
brought across into the Death Watch
faction now the armor also brings up
lariats which are basically ropes it was
actually a Lariat of armistice in the
cannon and this was an unbreakable rope
similar to the magic one that Brado and
Sam had in Lord of the Rings speaking of
Lord of the Rings there was a scene in
that in which Galadriel showed
frodovation in her magic bowl and the
forge is sort of used as a similar
framing device at this point in the
episode the armor begins to shape the
steel and she talks about how this
relates to the life of a Mandalorian
they are built from the ground up and
forged through trials and tribulations
that end up making them it allows us to
travel back to the past and from here we
learn what happened with grogu during
order 66. now go to 66 is taking a lot
of prominence in Star Wars shows
recently we of course saw Snippets of
what happened with grogu all the way
back in season 2 and Obi-Wan opened with
riva's story which echoed what we saw in
the show both Fallen order in the bad
batch season 1 had it playing at as well
and here we see what happened with
another young Jedi that was involved in
it this was a great Purge similar to
what happened on Mandalore in the night
of a thousand tiers and it's one of the
defining events in Star Wars history
everything changed from this point
onwards with the Empire taking over and
the Jedi losing their control they were
the Guardians for generations and we see
how in their stared that the new
Republic isn't really up to scratch this
is what allowed the first order to rise
up and due to Jedi being all but extinct
the Imperials gained a foothold once
more anyway we get a continuation of the
scene from season 2 and see what really
happened early on we hear the name
kelleran and we end up meeting him later
on in this scene kelleran first appeared
in the Jedi Temple challenge episode 1
and he carried the nickname saber in
that he was primarily a Jedi master that
supervised padawans and he carried with
him two droids in 83 and LX of 5. this
pair with protocol and Astromech droids
which gave him a similar setup to what
Luke had with the repeal and R2 it makes
sense that they try and get groga to
kaloran as he was a teacher that led
Jedi in the trials and he was known for
his kindness towards younglings I don't
know what the feedback to him rescuing
grogu is yet as we're making this pretty
early and I know people hoped it would
be someone like Mace Windu or another
big Jedi but shut the [__] up for a
second I'm gonna tell you why this scene
is great so color I'm back is played by
none other than Ahmed best he's appeared
in Star Wars before and in case you
don't know this is the guy who was
George or Binks in the prequel trilogy
Best has talked a lot about the backlash
that he got from playing the character
and how it pretty much ruined his entire
life however this very much redeems him
and you know I'm not gonna lie I
actually had tears in my eyes thinking
about how this guy waited over 20 years
to finally live all that stuff down Misa
was thinking it was great you know what
I'm not even gonna do a craft joke as
this did hit me emotionally a bit and
yeah it was nice seeing him just finally
get this Redemption that he's waited so
long for Keller and back builds off the
back of Ahmed Beck who's also a
character that appeared in the
background of attack of the Clones it's
been confirmed now that the pair are
related and you the same Act of playing
them both I'm guessing that they are
twins or something either way kelleran
gets a great scene where he races
through the Skies of chorusand and we
see the Jedi Temple burning in the
background behind him he shows his
prowess with a lightsaber and it's such
a good moment for the guy it was great
finally getting this filled in and
Keller makes it to a tunnel similar to
chasing an attack of the Clones be once
more passed the peak of the highest
mountain in Coruscant and this of course
popped up in last week's episode when it
was seen as a tourist attraction yeah
the feeling is completely different but
we still see that the civilians have
little to no idea what's going on they
were thrown into a dictatorship
overnight and had absolutely no chance
to react to what was happening before
them we mentioned the crystal Knack in
another episode breakdowns but that was
a similar situation where the German
Army stormed in and changed things
completely in the space of a few hours
calorim makes it of the landing platform
and we see the h-type Nubian yard that
Padme used in Attack of the Clones
b-wings then swoop into attack piloted
by clone troopers and we know that these
were precursors to type by this a killer
run makes it a hyper space and we then
cut back to secragu once more getting
given some armor this is a role of
Mandalorian steel and this is placed
over his chest on top of the mithril
vestigon book of Boba Fett look I know
it's not mithril yet just just bear with
me now he has very much found a home
with the mandalorians the idea of
finding a new home is something we've
seen happening with several characters
who've popped up in this season Manda
was deemed as an apostate and he had to
replenish himself in the Living Waters
this was very much the case with BO2
whose followers had abandoned her after
she lost the darksaber Dr Pershing
initially lost his mother and he found a
home amongst the Empire trying to do the
right thing with cloning technology
however he then ended up losing his
position and power after the empire fell
and he tried to find friendship with
Elia Kane Elijah was also an imperial
and she ended up finding a home with the
new Republic there may still be other
things going on with her but we have
this theme constantly repeating
throughout the show and it's sort of
like poetry they rhyme although I also
love how the show is setting up these
different factions that are all kind of
as bad as each other last week we
watched the amnesty soldiers still
getting referred to his numbers like
they were with the Imperials and the
mind player was also used by the new
Republic lots of things going on and
it's basically a mate who's like all I
can see things from both sides actually
I can see it both bad anyway back with
the tribe we see them heading up into
the mountains and it's clear that Bo is
very much slotting into being a leader
she's made the leader of the war party
and with this brings the privilege that
she can have food at the fire or else
the rest have to hurry up and eat that
it's in a private corner like some
shameful moment you hide from your
parents you know what I'm talking about
when you run off to your other room now
she's clearly also found a new home
after losing hers I think that she's
very much trying to position herself at
the top anyway we cut to the morning and
see the mandalorians crouched around you
might notice that we can actually see
the shrie cork symbol on their shoulder
pads tying back to what we said earlier
using the lariats they climb the
Cliffside leads to such a cool mountain
climbing moment again I'm guessing this
has been used to potentially set up
things for later on in the season but
it's also a good way of showing how
competent the mandalorians are it only
their jet packs for everything and if
the situation calls for it it can of
course avoid using them all together
finally they spot the nest and they're
being a nest is the first clue that the
dragon creature has kids there I'm sure
it has some overly long Star Wars
creature name but just call it Dragon
bird thing and I think we should be okay
now like a bird it feeds its young from
its mouth and I don't know why it took
so long to hand this kid off but it
leads to a big action scene got lots of
flashes of bowling order at this moment
and in that you have a big fight with a
giant bat called grow Gog or on dathomir
after beating it in its cave you jump on
its back intake to the skies and this is
similar to what happens here now it's
important to bear in mind that Bo loses
her shoulder pad during this little
Shadows what comes at the end of the
episode similar to an 8080 they take
down the creatures using ropes managed
to get the kid back after tying up its
wings dumping it in the water it's eaten
by one of the crocodile creatures that
appeared in the first episode and this
was obviously ripping on Jurassic world
and the ending of that spoilers anyway
nice little bit of detail is that the
foulings reveal to be the child of Paz
and this Father and Son aesthetic is of
course murder and grogu and din I'm
guessing that the armor is his mother
but maybe not because they didn't seem
that bothered when he got picked up at
the start might be after a break I'm
sure you parents understand now this
begs a massive question if it is his
mother and that is do they take their
helmets off when they're making babies
anyway this does show why Paz through
himself in the mouth of the Beast and it
was a nice little addition to the story
I think about has been redeemed by
saving the foundling and we see some
more in the dragon birds things kids
guessing these will mature and grow and
they can be used later down the line at
some point in the series the armor asks
if Bo wants a night owl embossed on her
new shoulder pad but Bo goes with the
mythical and this carries a lot with it
since seeing it in the Living Waters I
genuinely think she now believes she's
on the path to becoming the planet's
leader once more but whether the people
believe her or not is another thing
entirely the Arma does kind of humor her
but she doesn't seem as gobsmacked as
you would think and therefore it might
take Bo taking them back to the planet
to actually convince them all but upon
doing this she might be seen as the
leader as she's the first person to see
a metasaur since they were deemed as
being extinct now that would prop her up
in a great position of power however we
have din on the other side who's the
wielder of the darksaber thus the
conflict will likely be over who to
really follow as you can't really be the
leader of Mandalore if you don't wield
it this is another issue that popped up
with Bo's sister satin and it's split
the Creed right down the middle so a
similar thing could be happening here
and as we talked about before pride is a
massive thing that the mandalorians
carry it's What's led to so many Civil
Wars over the centuries and it's
possible that they could be sleepwalking
into another one now as for my thoughts
on this episode you know it was a short
episode but it did pack a lot of
emotional punches and you know if it
gets me tearing up there was some dust
in the room to be fair it gets me
tearing up a bit then I feel like it's
done its job however I don't think that
it's really delivering a massive story
beats and instead a lot of things that
happen in this were based around action
scenes and cool little reveals but yeah
it's still hit on an emotional level
um and at this point in the season you
know I'm fully on board I have enjoyed
everything they've done so far but I'm
not sure if it's a 10 out of 10. so as
were my thoughts on the season so far
because we are at the halfway point I
think it's been really solid with a
couple of super high points but the show
is still kind of finding its feet and
you know it does kind of feel like that
Disney Plus shows yeah they have this
weird thing where because they're not
slotted into an hour of TV that you
never really know what you're gonna get
for example some weeks you can get an
hour long episode and the next is just
half an hour which can lead to the
pacing feeling disjointed sometimes you
end up for the Long Haul and then the
next week it's over and done with
quicker than a heavy spoilers release I
I don't think my wife watches this
you're my number one subscriber
this I uh look I didn't mean that I
foreign
anyway I think it's been solid but yeah
we will see how things go over the next
couple of weeks before we probably have
another two or three year wait until the
next season can't believe that season
two was back in 2020 and I hope we get
some big bangs before the inevitable
wait uh obviously I know a lot of that
delay was down to the pandemic but yeah
let's just pray we get a really good
season anyway that wraps up the episode
and obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this entry we are in a
competition right now giving away the
Superman 4K box set to three subscribers
on the 15th of April and all you have to
do to be when the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments out random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on the screen right now
similar to you then message me on to
wear out heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch make sure you
check out one of our breakdowns on
screen now now I hope to see you over
there mate if I'm sorry if this video
has done your head in but yeah hopefully
see you over there and without the way
I've been Paul you've been the best see
you next time take care peace